字幕: Mimi Uzura
校正: Emi Atarashi
皆さん サンダーバードっていう人形劇を
ご存知でしょうか
1960年代ぐらいに放送された
人形劇なんですけれども
大筋をお話すると
南の島にですね
トレーシー家という家族は島を持って
そこを秘密基地に変えて
面白いメカを発進させて
世界の事件を解決していくという話なんですね
私 このサンダーバードというお話が
幼少期に大好きでした
なぜかというと
この秘密基地というこの世界観が
なんだかとっても
ワクワクしていたんですね
そんな秘密基地大好き少年森本くん（本人）も
大きくなって
大学生になったんですけれども
大学に入学した当初はですね
何がしたいか いまいちわからず
なんとなくぼーっと
日々を過ごしてたんですけれども
だんだんね この４年間
ぼーっと過ごすのかなと思うと焦ってきて
何か熱中できるもの
強烈にのめり込めるものを探してたんですね
そんなある日 僕がいつも行っている美容室で
雑誌をパラパラと見ていた時に
キャンピングカーの雑誌を見かけるんですね
何かこうキャンピングカー
車を秘密基地に変えて 世界を旅してる人たち
この雑誌を目にしたときに
僕は直感的に思うんですね
あっ これ やりたいな
何か分かんないけど
キャンピングカーで旅はしてみたいな
何だかよく分からないけれども
何かちょっと秘密基地っぽくて
ワクワクするなって そう思うんですね
当時 パワーが 私は有り余っていましたので
これからですね... そこから私の人生は全て
キャンピングカーで旅をするということに
全てを捧げる日常が始まります
お金も 大学生なので ないので
キャンピングカーは
買えなかったんですけれども
実際にキャンピングカー作ってみよう
ということでですね
私 キャンピングカー作りました
ご説明しますと
この下にあるのが あれですね
農家さんが使っている軽自動車
軽トラですよね
軽トラの上に自分で木の箱をつくって
その中を秘密基地にして
これで生活したりとか キャンプするっていう
そういうプロジェクトを自分で立ち上げて
秘密基地生活をエンジョイしてました
最初は 大工さん
友人の大工さんと作ったんですけれども
大工さんと一緒に 土台からね
大工センター行って木を買ってきて
材料を買ってきて作っていたんですね
私キャンピングカーで旅をしたいと言いながら
実は免許は持っていなかったので
この上の箱のみを作って
実家の駐車場に建てたんですね
６カ月間 放置したんですけれども
当然両親はついに息子は頭がおかしくなって
しまったのかと そんな感じでいたんですが
私は秘密基地ライフができると思って
とっても満足していました
秘密基地の内装もすごくこだわっていて
僕は東京都調布市に住んでいるんですけれども
自分のお気に入りのハンバーガー屋さんが
実は近くにありまして
そこは内装がウエスタンの
西部開拓時代のデザインなんですね
私 そこのハンバーガー屋さんに行ったときに
うわっ このデザインめちゃくちゃ格好いいな
何か開拓してる
俺も何か開拓したいし
なんか デザイン
めちゃくちゃいいじゃんと思って
自分もこのデザイン真似しようと思って
実は キャンピングカーの中を こんな風に
インテリアをデザインしたりしていました
こんな活動していると
いろんな方と出会う機会を得まして
こちらですね 立教の５号館ですね
こちらにある立教の５号館の裏に
駐車場を持っている地主さんが
私にこのキャンピングカーのプロジェクトを
面白いからこれを立教大学の裏に停めて
何か生活してみたらどうだという提案を
いただきましてですね
実は私 大学３年生頃 立教の裏に
ちょっと住んでいた時期がありました
これは借り別荘みたいな感じですよね
そうするとですね 大学の友人や地域の人が
遊びに来てくれるんですね
こんな感じでビールを飲んだりなんかしながら
楽しい生活を送っていました
唯一の欠点としては 朝起きた時に
トイレが車には付いてないので
走って裏のコンビニまで
行かなきゃだめっていうね
これはすごく大変だったんですけれども
何にせよ 楽しい秘密基地ライフを
送っていたんです
私 日本では飽き足らず
海外でも同じように 秘密基地で
旅がしてみたいなと思うようになります
直近 実は３か月ですね
私はアメリカの西海岸の方に渡り
中古で車を購入して 秘密基地に変えて
アメリカ全土を旅していました
そうするとですね
アメリカは非常にユニークな
個性あふれる国ですから
僕と同じように秘密基地で旅をしている方が
たくさんいらっしゃったんですね
こちら 見かけたんですけれども
そうですね バスを改造して
何か上で 何か遊んでる人がいたりとか
上で焚き火している人なんかいたりとか
もうどういうことなんだっていう状態
面白い方がいたりだとか
一番驚いたのはですね
救急車を日本から輸入して
中に住んでいますっていう
犬と住んでますって方がいたりとか
いや 僕 日本人だったら ちょっとね
怖い... なんか...
昔 医療用で使ってたってことはね
何かお化けとかでそうじゃない？
みたいな感じで聞いたんですけど
「私 自分でお祓いしたから大丈夫」
とか言ってね
本当なのか？みたいなところ
あるんですけれども
彼らは自分の秘密基地を
すごくユニークに改装して凄い旅をする
楽しいライフスタイルを送っていたんですね
そんな彼らは
自分の秘密基地で旅をするライフスタイルを
こんな言葉で表現していました
「バンライフ」
あんまり聞き慣れない言葉ですね
バンライフ
私 バンライフっていうのが
何なのかと思って
ちょっとグーグルでね
検索してみたんですよ
バンライフとは「車中泊」
本当なんですかねぇ
他にもいろいろ「キャンプ」とか「車旅」
みたいな感じで いろいろ定義が出てきてて
まだ どうやら 定義が定まっていない
言葉のような感じがするんですね
そこで私 今回の TEDトークで
この「バンライフ」という言葉を
定義したいなというふうに
考えております
この中にね ウィキペディアを
書き変えられる方がいたら
是非ね こんな風に書きかえてほしいな
というふうに考えております
すなわち バンライフとは
「秘密基地で旅をすること」
秘密基地で旅
大好きですね 僕
すげーワクワクしますね
もしかしたら 会場の中の皆さんにも
秘密基地や旅という言葉にワクワクする人が
いるんじゃないでしょうか
幼少期に遊んだりですとかね
僕 ここで１つ思うんですけれども
なぜ私は そして会場の皆さんは
そして人類は
「秘密基地」と「旅」というこの２つの言葉に
ワクワクするんでしょうか？
私 これ調べてみたところ
非常に面白い 人間の本能と
結びついた理由があったんですね
まずは秘密基地の方から
ご説明しましょう
皆さんの中でもね
幼少期に秘密基地ごっこ
もしかしたらしたことある人
いるんじゃないでしょうか
僕は秘密基地大好きで 10歳ぐらいまで
ほぼ秘密基地ごっこばかりしましたね
秘密基地 実は
秘密基地ごっこというものは
人間が敵に遭遇した時に
その敵から隠れるための
練習に値する行為らしいんですね
子どもの時は...
人間の本能には敵に遭遇した時に
戦ったりだとか 逃げるっていう行為が
本能に定まっているらしいんですけれども
子どもは力がないので まずは隠れる練習を
どうやらするようなんですね
人間の隠れるという行為は
非常に面白くて
「敵が来た 危ない」と思って脳に大量に
アドレナリンを放出するらしいんですが
同時に
隠れる秘密基地があるから
隠れる行為によって
安心感を得ることができる
すなわち 同時に危ないと思いながらも
安心感を得ている
こういう状態が 秘密基地ごっこの
ワクワクの正体だったんですね
次に 旅の説明に行きましょう
「旅」 我々の人類が長い間
旅をしてきたと言われていますが
なぜ人間が旅をしたいかという理由
については 諸説あると言われてるんですね
私 でも この中で
最も面白いなと思った理由が
実は１つあります
それは旅が人類しかすることができない行為だ
ということですね
どういうことかというと
人間以外の動物は旅をすることができない
という意味らしいんですよ
人間以外の動物は
あるコミュニティーから外に出た時に
その相手を受け入れることが
できないらしいんですね
部外者として排除してしまうという
特性があるんですね
また その人が戻って
動物が元のコミュニティーに戻ってきた時も
同じ場所で戻してあげることが
できないんですね
ところが 人間は
戻してあげることもできるし
他から来た動物を受け入れてあげる...
（言い間違え）
［他から来た］人間を受け入れてあげることも
できるという
面白い特性を持ってるんですね
この「受け入れてあげられる特性」というのが
我々と旅の 20万年に渡る 長い長い歴史を
作ってきたんじゃないか
というふうに私は考えてます
この20万年の歴史というのが
私たちの本能に
「何か新しいものを知りたい」
「冒険したい」
そんな冒険心を埋め込んだんじゃないか
というふうに考えています
さて バンライフの話に戻りましょう
バンライフとは
秘密基地旅ですね
「旅」 新しいものを開拓していく
「新しいものを知りたい」
「見たい」「知りたい」
そういうワクワクの中で敵に遭遇する
敵に遭遇するときに 興奮しながらも
「あっ 自分は隠れ家があるから大丈夫」
この２つの本能を合致させた
エンターテインメントなんじゃないかと
私は考えています
いかがだったでしょうか
秘密基地で旅がしたくなってきたんじゃ
ないでしょうか
私はあなた方のバンライフを待っています
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）